PROFESSOR: Hi everyone.
Welcome back.
So today, we're
going to take a look
at some forced oscillators
and the exponential response
formula.
And the problem we're going
to take a look at is first,
for part one, to consider the
equation x dot dot plus 8x
equals, and then a forcing
term on the right-hand side,
cosine omega*t.
And we're going to consider the
case when omega squared is not
equal to 8.
So in the language of resonance,
we're not on resonance.
And we're also asked
why is this called
an undamped forced oscillator.
And then for part
two, to use the ERF
to solve the differential
equation x dot
dot plus 2x dot plus
4x equals cosine 3t.
And then, what is the
natural angular frequency
of this differential equation?
So I'll let you take a
look at these problems
and try them out for yourself.
And I'll be back in a moment.
Hi everyone.
Welcome back.
So we're asked to find
the general solution
to the differential equation,
x dot dot plus 8x equals cosine
omega*t.
And notice how this is
a differential equation
with constant coefficients.
But it's being forced
by a periodic function
on the right-hand side.
So the first thing to
do is to write down
the homogeneous solution.
So the homogeneous
solution, which
I'll denote with a subscript
h, solves the differential
equation with the
right-hand side of 0.
This gives us a
characteristic polynomial of s
squared plus 8 equals 0,
which then gives us roots
of plus or minus root 8 i.
So the homogeneous solution
is some constant c_1.
And when we have
purely imaginary roots,
we have cosine of the
imaginary term times t,
plus some constant c_2 times
sine of the imaginary term,
which in this case is root 8 t.
So the homogeneous solution is
always contains two constants.
And it solves the
differential equation
with a zero right-hand side.
The general solution, however,
is the homogeneous solution
plus one particular solution
that solves the differential
equation 8 dot dot plus
8x equals cosine omega*t.
So we just need to find one
solution to this differential
equation.
And in this case, I'll use the
exponential response formula.
But first note that when we
use the exponential response
formula, we need a forcing
to be of the form e to s*t
on the right-hand side.
And cosine omega*t
is not in that form.
However, what we
can do is there's
a trick to complexify
the right-hand side.
So we note that the cosine
omega*t is actually the real
part of i*omega*t.
So what this means is if we
have a complex solution, zed,
which solves z dot dot plus
8z equals e to the i*omega*t,
then we can take x equals
the real part of z,
then solves the differential
equation x dot dot plus 8x
equals the real part
of the right-hand side,
cosine omega*t.
And now we're in business
because this equation
has the form where we can
use the exponential response
formula.
So solving this
differential equation for z,
we have a particular
solution for z,
is going to be e to
the i*omega*t divided
by the characteristic polynomial
evaluated at the exponential.
So in this case, the
exponential is i*omega.
So we must evaluate the
polynomial at i*omega.
And this is the solution
provided that the polynomial
evaluated at i*omega
doesn't vanish.
And in our case, the
characteristic polynomial,
p of s, we worked out already
to be s squared plus 8.
So this gives us a
particular solution for z,
which is 1 divided by
i*omega squared plus 8
on the denominator.
We have e to i*omega
on the numerator.
And of course, 1 over i*omega
squared plus 8 becomes 1 over 8
minus omega squared.
And we know we
don't have a problem
because omega, we were
told in the problem,
is not equal to the
square root of 8.
So in this case, we know
that the denominator is not
going to vanish.
And now what we need
to do is just take x,
for the particular solution,
to be the real part of z,
which is going to be the real
part-- I'll write it out--
8 minus omega squared cosine
omega*t plus i sine omega*t,
which gives us 1 over 8 minus
omega squared cosine omega*t.
So the total solution,
the general solution,
is going to be the sum of
the homogeneous solution
plus the particular solution.
And in our case, that's going to
be c_1 cosine omega*t plus c_2
sine omega*t plus 1 over 8 minus
omega squared cosine omega*t.
Sorry.
These should be root 8's.
So this is the homogeneous part.
And this is the
particular solution.
general solution.
So we were asked, also, why
this is sometimes called
an undamped forced oscillator.
Well, it's undamped, because
in the differential equation,
there is no damping term.
There's no term
proportional to x dot.
And then, secondly, it's forced
because we have a forcing
on the right-hand side.
We have an input function, f,
which in this case is cosine
omega*t which
doesn't depend on x.
And that forces the
differential equation.
Also note that the
forcing term gives
rise to part of the
solution which is directly
proportional to the forcing.
In fact, it has
the same frequency
but a different amplitude.
So this concludes part A.
Now for part B,
we're asked to use
the ERF to solve
the differential
equation x dot dot plus 2x
dot plus 4x equals cosine 3t.
And again, we can
use the same trick.
The right-hand side isn't
of the form e to the i*3t.
But what we can do is we can
write cosine 3t as the real
part of e to the i*3t, and then
solve the differential equation
z dot dot plus 2z dot plus
4z equals e to the i*3t,
and then take x equals
the real part of z.
And in this case,
we're only looking
for a particular solution, which
we can compute using the ERF.
So it's 1 over the
characteristic polynomial
evaluated at 3i
times e to the i*3t.
And what's a
characteristic polynomial
of this differential equation?
Well, p of s is going to be s
squared plus 2s plus 4, which
means that p of 3i is going to
be 3i squared plus 2 times 3i
plus 4, which gives us negative
9 plus 4-- is negative 5--
plus 6i.
And putting the pieces together,
we end up getting that x is
equal to the real part of
1 over negative 5 plus 6i e
to the i*3t.
And we can expand out the
numerator using Euler's formula
to get cosine 3t plus i sine 3t.
And when the dust
settles, I got 1 over 61--
let me check my notes-- minus
5 cosine 3t plus 6 sine 3t.
So I'll let you work at
this last step for yourself.
And then, lastly, what is
the natural angular frequency
of the differential equation?
Well, this is just
some notation.
We sometimes call the
natural angular frequency
to be the square root of
the term proportional to x.
So in this case,
the term two here
comes in as a damping term.
The natural frequency,
which is sometimes
written as omega naught
squared, is always
equal to this term, which is 4.
So the natural frequency, the
natural angular frequency,
omega naught, would
be the square root
of 4, which would be 2.
So I just like to quickly recap.
We've taken a look at
forced oscillators.
And we computed their
solutions using the ERF.
And one common trend,
particularly when
we have an oscillating
input, a forcing term,
is to first change
the oscillating term
into a complex
exponential, then compute
a particular solution
using the ERF formula,
and then take the real
part of the ERF solution
to recover a real
solution to the ODE.
That gives us the
particular solution.
And then, in some
cases, we also have
to add the homogeneous
solution to it
to get the full general
solution to the ODE.
So I'd like to conclude here.
And I'll see you next time.